hi linda today we're looking at the
portrait of
emmanuel charpontier who is a french
microbiologist and a max planck director
here in berlin
she discovered crisprcas9 together with
her colleague
jennifer doudna and received the nobel
prize for it
this year so can you tell me what the
story is behind
emmanuel's picture you know at jennifer
dardner and
emmanuel japanese are totally different
personalities
you know i ask all of them to write
their philosophy or formula
of their hand and uh jennifer
wrote crispercus9 and
made a real drawing and emmanuel wrote
always be the best of yourself
and she told me it's important to
knowing yourself
to know your limits and also to
recognize the opportunities who should
take
and she
lived for almost for 30 years as a nomad
she was in usa in sweden in austria
germany and she told me she
loves to to live in different countries
it refreshes herself
and also she doesn't want to live in a
box it makes her scared
and also in 2011 she made a
collaboration with jennifer deutner
and developed crisper cast nine with
crystal class 9
you can change the dna not only in
plants
but also in humans and there's a
possibility the unwanted possibility
to create designer babies and she's
talking about that
and that you know it's a responsibility
of course of science but also about the
society
what they allow or not to allow